the only test a man's worth this battle  those rounds come screaming past your  head you're gonna learn if you're hungry  enough hungry enough to take that  victory we're gonna battle with the  soldiers that we used to be ghosts and  you better believe that they are hungry  too  once upon a time some of these ghosts  they may have been your friends and  there is brotherhood but then there is  what the world needs these ghosts they  are the past they still serve the  Machine that we left behind right now  for the future the world needs us  I'm honored I'm honored to be here with  you tonight  and as you head in the battle with that  mean look in your eye those bad  intentions in your mind remember this  you are the few with the courage to make  history  you had the desire to take victory you  will be on a battlefield full of ghosts  but only you  yeah  that makes you lose  [Music]  pre-order now for guaranteed beta access  you  you